in complete contrast in a way right
tattoos are very obvious red flag number
11. maybe there are some signs or maybe
there are some things we can look for to
distinguish a woman with a high Notch
count meaning have had lots of sexual
partners correct
yeah so this one is one that really
upsets women because they can't turn
back the clock on this once it's done
it's done
um you know they can try to dismiss it
well why can men do it but women can't
do it well again you know men and women
are different and promiscuity and women
affects them to a far greater degree
than it does men they've done studies on
this there's a very uh popular study
called the teachman study
um and I think they stopped collecting
the data after about 21 partners and I
think 21 Partners in today's world is
actually pretty conservative if you're
if you're talking a woman or dealing
with women over 25 or 30 she's probably
laid with more than 21 uh men but anyway
they stopped collecting the data at 21
and what they found was a woman that's a
virgin bride has about an 82 percent
chance of being happy in a marriage with
a man uh I think it's about seven or
eight years down the road report it
anyway
um and the more partners that she's been
with and it's a bouncing bar graph it
kind of goes down like this but but the
trend is down now basically the more
guys that she's been with the higher
probability is that she's going to be
unhappy and there's other issues that
come with that I mean she's been with
more guys a higher probability that
she's had abortions the higher
probability she's got an STD the higher
probability she has a mental disorder or
she's on some kind of meds to sort of
medicate it or placate it uh the biggest
risks that exists beyond all of that and
the absolute disgust that most men tend
to realize exists when they picture a
woman laying with 50 or 100 other guys
prior to them is that if you're going to
raise a family and have kids or even if
you're going to be in a long-term
relationship uh if a woman's been
through a lot of guys a lot of
relationships it's very easy for her to
leave and exit so she's not very sticky
to you you know she doesn't she a woman
that has conflict in a relationship
that's been with a lot of guys were just
like I'm out because I can just find
somebody else I had this conversation
the other day with a close friend and
he's read my book he's known about me
for a long time because we're friends
and he overlooked the notch Camp thing
he actually came to me and he said hey
look rich I think you need to add
Runners to your list and I said what do
you mean by Runners he goes you know
women that run at the first sign of
conflict or problems so I went so I kind
of rewound I said well explain to me
what she's about and let's go through
the red flags with you and he's like
okay well there's the notch count thing
I'm like okay well what do you think the
notch count is he says well
she she couldn't identify it you know we
had the conversation it was it was too
many to name
so I'm like what do you think that means
20 50. he goes well the last time we
broke up
she basically contacted every guy that
she's ever been with to try to line them
up to placate herself to get the
attention that she needed so he said
Runners are a potential roadside but I
argue I said look the reason why she's a
runner is because she's promiscuous and
it's easy for her to leave if there's
conflict in the relationship because
if it's been 21 guys and you're number
22 she doesn't care she'll make it 23 24
25 right there's there's no intention to
maintain purity
in that Dynamic which is why when she's
unhappy she'll just find the next guy
because she knows it's easy
I think I learned the term pair bonding
from uh watching your videos is this a
thing is this where is this a real thing
where a certain amount of after a
certain amount of men a woman lacks the
ability now to pair bond which is
terabonda healthy and happy way right
again like what
what if you've been with a woman that's
we'll just use 50. we'll use something
random like that you know if you've been
with a woman that's been with 50 guys
the chances of her having abortions the
chances of her having a lot of baggage
along the way is is there it exists
versus a woman that might have spent her
entire 20s with one guy and maybe he was
a total POS and she had to end it and
now she's with you or she's a virgin
Bride for example let's say
um she's she's just got a lot of baggage
so the example that I use and if I were
to take a sharpie marker and grab a clay
brick and write on it he heard me put
that in the burlap bag he threw me down
the stairs put that in the burlap bag he
abandoned me when I got pregnant put
that in the burlap bag I had to have an
abortion put that it's like a big burlap
bag full of bricks and she carries
around and it's invisible and nobody
sees it except for her she knows that
it's there it exists and she doesn't
tend to recognize sorry reconcile all of
those bad choices in her life and she
carries us around and now she carries
this heavy bag of bricks around into
your life as you invite her into it and
you're dealing with the trauma and past
issues that she's had so it's not just
the discuss of her laying with many men
it's not just the potential for an STD
all of those things there's there's a
lot of compounding issues there and look
if you're dating and you know you're
spinning Place whatever it is you happen
to be doing sort of you know figure out
women that's fine but if you discover
that she's been promiscuous I would not
invite her into my life it's it's just a
bad choice
yeah I wouldn't argue with that
um my question though is
no one's walking around with a Scarlet
Letter how do you know how you know
there are any subtle signs or symptoms
of a woman who has an eye
you know if you ask her directly people
argue that you should just double or
triple whatever number she gives you
right okay is a is an easy way to do it
because women will tend to uh like
they'll recall long longer term
relationships they'll recall the
three-month guy that she dated the seven
month guy the three-year relationship
she'll recall all of that what she
doesn't tend to recall is well what
happened in Vegas stays in Vegas what
happened at the foam Cannon party and
Ibiza stays there the threesome
encounters the lesbian encounters the
guy that she gave a to at the
back of the nightclub
um she doesn't recall those numbers so
that's why they say well you can double
or triple whatever number sheet she
gives you so if it if it starts looking
like promiscuity like if it walks like a
duck and it quacks like a duck it's
probably duck a lot of the Red Flags
over here by the way
um sort of sort of are indicators of
promiscuity she's had daddy issues she's
a feminist like for you to be a feminist
you have to think that men and women are
identical and one of the beliefs that
women have as well as men can be
promiscuous then women can be
promiscuous now because we have birth
control we can do whatever we want right
so a feminist woman is typically quite
promiscuous whereas a more conservative
woman isn't so a lot of those on the
list of the red flags are good
identifiers but a simple way to be you
know at some point down the line when
you're dating
curious you know how many guys have you
been with and they just shut up and let
her talk and let her say whatever she
wants she might downplay it she might
not answer the question directly a more
difficult way to assess it would be to
just watch her lifestyle Behavior so you
meet a woman she's 33. hey what'd you do
with your 20s well you know I backpacked
around Europe I worked on cruise ships I
worked at a nightclub I did some
promotion work uh I was uh working in
Ibiza for three years you can you know
you can rest assured that she's been
with a lot of dudes if you take a look
at her Instagram and she doesn't have a
lot of money but you see a lot of
photographs on Yachts private jets boats
super cars well guess who's paying for
all that right you know in exchange for
the photograph for that opportunity to
be in that photograph there's a guy that
typically pays for that and it's not
always the same guy usually
okay those are those are helpful I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out